ONUTE TOO.
>> Chris: BROGDON --
>> Quinn: MYLES KNOCKED THAT ONE
OUT AGAIN.
>> Chris: THIRD CHANCE FOR THE
LAKERS.
>> Quinn: THE BEST OPPORTUNITY
IS TO GO OVERTIME.
YOU'VE GOT LEGS WITH A LOT OF
MILES ON THEM.
>> Chris: SABONIS PLAYING WITH
FIVE FOULS.
>> Quinn: HE WANTS TO GO LEFT.
PACERS DID THE RIGHT THING.
THEY DOUBLE TEAMED.
ELECTS TO GO LEFT.
THAT'S HIS THING.
YOU'VE GOT TO KNOW THAT.
>> Chris: JAMES WITH HIS FOURTH
THREE.
>> Quinn: SABONIS MAKES IT HARD
FOR HIM TO CLOSE BECAUSE HE CAN
GO AROUND SAVENLTS
>> Chris: HE HAS MATCHED HIS
SEASON HIGH.
THAT'S KNOCKED AWAY.
JAMES MADE THE DEFENSIVE PLAY.
>> Quinn: CARRIED THE BALL.
NO QUESTION.
DISCONTINUED DRIBBLE.
DOUBLE DRIBBLE.
CARRIED THE BALL.
YOU CALL IT WHAT YOU WANT.
WHAT IS LEBRON LOOKING -- WE'VE
GOT A FAN THAT'S GOT A LITTLE
UNRULY AND LEBRON IS POINTING IT
OUT TO THE OFFICIALS.
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO IS
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT HIM OUT.
I WOULDN'T KNOW WHAT THEY SAID.
THEY'RE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COURT.
BUT THEY'RE PULLING THEM OUT.
LISTEN.
WE WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO COME TO
THE GAMES.
PLEASE.
BUT DON'T GET YOURSELF THROWN
OUT.
>> Chris: NO.
>> Quinn: NONE OF US WANTS YOU
THROWN OUT BUT HE WENT RIGHT TO
THE OFFICIAL AND GOT THAT COUPLE
THROWN OUT.
>> Chris: PACERS DOWN THREE.
>> Quinn: THIS IS THE GUY YOU
WANT TO ATTACK -- OH, MYLES HAD
FALLEN AND WAS TRYING TO GET UP.